hollywood wasser
murat ernsthaft so herzlich willkommen
zum war zwölf minuten manchmal auch ein
bisschen mehr
heute sitzen cooles video der genießt
leider nicht da und ich habe lust und
kochen hier zumachen und hab heute zu
gast den lieben volkan der wird gleich
kommt und ich war natürlich vor
das wird ein veganes gerichts bei burka
ist veganer wir müssen jetzt nicht
belegen dafür
er kann nichts dafür er ist halt so wir
machen auch kein held zum veganer
da haben wir nicht weil wir gerade mit
sein und zwar alle kurzen nun veganer
der lässt einfahren
wir machen auch kein herz von veganer
weil sie nicht gut weil ich gut ich
glaube dass sie gleich daran dass er
nicht wie es passt fahren ist was er
kann man fan einblenden lassen fahren
ist also wenn du vor 2000 geboren ein
bisschen schon mal im wald warst das ist
einfach blöd lass uns lieber hat keiner
gelacht komisch oder
aber wir haben heute ein ganz cooles
veganes gerichts habt keine angst der
schritt wirklich gut
und wie gesagt wir begrüßen jetzt mal
schön den wolken lockern
daher kommt dank solcher in saarbrücken
ist ein teil unseres teams
er ist der produktdesigner macht designs
verschiedene designs spricht perfekt
englisch spricht gut deutsch geht seit
zwei jahren ist in deutschland und du
spricht gut deutsch
das geht sehr gutes deutsch es cool ist
ich werde schon mal erzählt burkhard
einen coolen akzent weil er hat es in
london gewesen jahrelang er war in dubai
spricht perfekt englisch und durch das
englische hatte einen deutsch englischen
aktien kein türkisch deutschen aktien
sondern englisch deutschen aktien genau
so verhalten wie hört sich kulant wenn
man ab und zu finden die worte dann
kommt er auf englisch mal was kein
problem
icann speak english is not for you don't
know you're just ev bme okay
das heißt wir werden ab und zu mal ins
englische ableiten natürlich war ich
hauptschule achte klasse leistungskurs
englisch mache ich nicht der beste okay
zum anfangen genaueres regensburg hat
ist egal was schon seit wir ja noch mal
über drei jahren drei jahren genau warum
erzählt mir das zu weit kann es ist war
ganz einfach weil er veganer ist egal
erzählt immer gerne massiv dass die
veganer sind richtig ja da fällt mir
gerade noch mit sein will kann
warum waren noch nie in veganer auf dem
mond weiß keiner
veganer dann oben da oben keiner ziehen
kann dass veganer ist wir machen auch
keine hates me veganer
köhler war gut die sind so schlecht dass
dieser schlechte veganer wie z
es ist ein wahnsinn also ich bin auch
kein anti veganer ich find's cool man
kann sich die fast egal ob genau man
kann sich einfach jemand der wirklich
sagt er möchte qualitativ hochwertiges
fleisch kann sich definitiv für jeden
tag fleisch leisten weil ein qualitativ
hochwertiges fleisch ist euer richtig
genau artgerechte haltung gesprächen
hand und man kann kein biologen für
sechs euro kaufen das ist mir absolut
lüge
das gibt es nicht habe ich recht genau
und wir machen jetzt was cooles beim
coolen fleischersatz muss ich langsam
zeit schmeckt einfach besser als fleisch
richtig so wir machen heute war es
traditionell türkisches aber ist es auch
indisch angehauchten richtig dass ja es
gibt auch ähnliche cousine ist nur gut
ähnliche cousinen das heißt indische
küche wohl damit sagen ja ich hab's euch
aber noch mal übersetzt war ja ihr wisst
ja irgendwie auch gut so volkan wehrt
geklaut die in die türken ich weiß nicht
ich glaube in der vergangenheit in
indien dasselbe empire war so lange dass
dabei empfahl das waren die friseurinnen
nicht fahrbar empire the empire bücher
zum beispiel ist halt immer haarscharf
ok hast vergessen egal auf jeden fall
mitte hier okay da fangen wir mit dem
kochen so mir vor wie eine geschichte
aus schriften volkan es wahnsinnig
intelligent genau und was sagen passt so
intelligent wie ich arbeite mache ich
weiter so wir machen not je mehr heißt
es auch wirklich genau noticed
kichererbsen kichererbsen in
proteinreichen sie sind viele
mineralstoffe viel energie das hält jung
man sieht sein die du stürzt sich ernst
und spaß mein lieber scholli volkan ist
40 ihr könnt ruhig volkan abc ihnen
sagen so witzig
okay er ist richtig schlank
das heißt natürlich dass nicht kochen
kann weil wir könnte dann so aussehen
wie ich ja auf jeden fall cool
also fangen an jagd nach den zutaten ok
dann machen wir mal die zutaten für
unser team
genau gleich mitreißen die zutaten
hergerichtet und zwar folgendes das ist
das rezept ist für vier personen gedacht
und da wolkig haben wir noch gedacht am
schluss machen wir noch ein salat dazu
und zwar nennt sich das kasseler präsent
ist nennt sich löffel salat
doch weil man das ist nicht richtig man
scheint der so klein
das muss richtig läuft es gut dass für
vier personen wenn wir mal hier
für dieses komplette menü für vier
personen mal ein bisschen nachrechnet
landmann so ungefähr bei zwischen zehn
und zwölf euro
denn auch mal maximal genug sagen genau
paar sachen mehr daheim sondern ein
normaler weise aber zwischen zehn und
zwölf euro landet man hier mit vier
personen für den coolen geschichte lang
habt ja ungesund und gesundes aufnehmen
also gesund ist extrem gesund es sind
keine verarbeiteten lebensmitteln ganz
ganz wichtig nein stimmt nicht keine
verarbeiteten lebensmittel finde ich
cool
das heißt wenn ihr einfach gesund leben
möchte dann benutzt einfach keine
verarbeiten lebenswichtig beste tipp was
du machen kannst
absolut um auch schlank zu bleiben zum
beispiel ist kann sie zu mir
schlank jugendleiter jung geblieben auch
und ja auch nicht übertreiben fangen mit
den zutaten an
und die kommen jetzt hier haben wir 200
gramm basmatireis dann 80 boni bekommt
die über einen türkischen laden diese
promis ganz normal ist nicht zu schaffen
dann haben wir hier fünf tomaten dann
haben wir kick herbst schon der dose
normalerweise muss mutti herbst immer
einen tag vorher das machen wir nicht
aber keine zeit dazu aber es wird nicht
nur kichererbsen im wasser dann haben
wir hier zwei rote zwiebeln rote zwiebel
haben antioxidantien das heißt es hätte
ich natürlich jung ist aber auch cool
ist rote zwiebel haben auch den ruf für
krebs prophylaxe das heißt kann krebs
verhindert ja muss aber nicht kann es
aber ist auf jeden fall besser als
normale zwiebeln und schmeckt auch
besser als ich kaufe immer positiv oder
zum kauf immer auch im salat vor allem
ja ich bin eben auf den salat genau
genau rote zwiebel ist cool
dann haben wir hier zwei patzer
kartoffeln ganz ganz wichtig wenn es
hier keine kartoffeln abfalls habt dann
funktioniert leider nicht mehr hat er
pech gehabt sagt dann haben wir hier
eine karotte
die ist auch nicht schön aber gesund
da mal hier petersilie weil der
petersilie ganz ganz wichtig es gibt die
deutsche petersilie und es gibt die
türkische wäre das sehr genau und zwar
bitte nicht die causa sie deutschen
schmeckt furchtbar habe ich recht ja das
trifft genau in den klub hätte sie dann
eben ganz ganz wichtig krieg im
türkischen laden kriegt aber auch unter
anderem im gut sortierten fachen richtig
genau und wie eine keine glatte
petersilie habt dann macht es nicht dann
geht zum mcdonald's oder burger weil
sonst das gericht nicht möglich ok so
viel mehr ist aber schon mal gleich
klare kante gesetz macht das bitte genau
so wäre es nicht so macht dann geht es
nicht so dann haben wir hier einen
halben teelöffel salz
es ist mehr aber jetzt nur ein teelöffel
drin dann haben wir hier auch ein halber
teelöffel dann haben wir ein halben
teelöffel chiliflocken dann haben wir
hier so mack und zwar so markt ist eine
alte zutat kann immer früher in
deutschland auch ist er verschwunden das
nennt sich essig bauen gewürz richtig
genial in der türkischen küche überall
essig gewürzt schmeckt richtig lecker
hat mir gewisse säure drin aber auch
nicht leicht unterton als schärfe habe
ich nicht folgerichtig zwar ist es
richtig cool und dann haben wir noch ein
teelöffel minzen toppen
er ist aus unserem eigenen garten dann
habe ich getrocknet und traf genau ins
eck moreno hat ja ok woran hat es
gemacht und zwar im backofen welt der
hdr funktion geniale geschichte wusstest
du dass das stimmt ja super auf jeden
fall das sind die zutaten für unser nur
mut nur noch okay not the way heißt
einfach not essen für den salat haben in
lego caddy ist auf unserem garten kein
witz echter wahnsinn immer noch wir
haben herbst dann haben wir hier noch
boni und zwar auch so viel ihr wollt
hier haben ungefähr zehn stück dann
haben wir hier frisch vier frische
tomaten eine rote zwiebel und das
besondere hier dran ist noch eine
branche und zwar ist die von san luca
ist keine produktplatzierung aber ich
kenne den besitzer so auf jeden fall
dann haben noch was ganz besonders für
die türkische küche ist natürlich total
verrückt die türken trainer 3 durch die
sich granata visierung und zwar 100
und hier haben noch zwei esslöffel öl
zwei esslöffel öl das sich auf wenn das
rad was wir vergessen habe ich noch
aufgefallen beim note mir braucht ja
auch immer zwei esslöffel olivenöl genau
beim öl bei türkischen gerichten
natürlich immer olivenöl ist der
wahnsinn das ist nämlich eins wissen
beim braten gibt es ein raffiniertes öl
oder gibt es ein kaltgepresst bei
solchen speisen
das weiß ich warum werde ich gesucht
habe die ganze nacht davor schon ich
habe mich immer wie zutaten informiert
ich weiß überall wo was weiß ich
inzwischen alles gelesen was genau und
jetzt fangen wir an natürlich wie gesagt
bei dem veganern fing man im schnitt du
bist schnippelt er du kannst stimme ging
das hat man auf englisch sagt schneiden
ließ und japan lässt also baggerfahrer
mit einem schnippeln und während
durchschnitt ist gewiss noch erzählen
okay okay ich bin ja nicht du schon mal
obst die karotte davor ein bisschen
schneiden und schälen richtig so die
karotten sind übrigens auch von uns aber
nicht von uns und zwar der nachbar
hatten wir wohnen direkt an einem
feldrand und der anbau und von dogs in
die karten laster zusammen ihrer wahl zu
gehen auf jeden fall die karten kann man
direkt danach war klar das ist okay so
viel und jetzt stehen
ich wollte cool aus scheler volkan
volkan wie gesagt er macht bei uns das
ganze produkt design und die cela die
idee der vulkan macht die technische
realisierung lichter alter siamak
tschuldigung und du machst dir sagen
würde du denkst immer was dabei unter
anderem hier erzählen was über dieses
messer ja das ist das japanische gemüse
ist an der kieler uni wien holzgriff in
den oliven holzgriff genommen das land
gepackt immunsystem und bakterien also
so gut arbeiten
in den kühlen mit olivenholz zum
beispiel das ist auch das ist auch
richtig und bakterien und das ist vg
feldstein damaskus 76 naja lebenslagen
genau genau das ist das hat einfach
extrem gut ball an und es ist perfekt
veganer warum wir immer sagen sagt
gemüse genau man hält es auch so geht es
auch bei der handynutzung noch kann es
auch normaler fleischesser benutzen du
kannst wir haben auch über fleisch und
sagen okay alles da und ich habe die
karte auch schon geschrieben ja so
schwierig die tomaten kartoffeln
[Musik]
so kartoffel ganz klein schneiden kann
ich euch so kleine genannten müssen sich
vorgaben sondern können direkt anzugehen
ganz klar klein schneiden klein
[Musik]
so etwas klein geschnitten genau umso
kleiner umso schneller geht's jetzt
nehmen das alles in den topf und
anbraten kollege mit olivenöl dann aber
zwei esslöffel dann immer zwei es laufen
lässt bester 5 habe ich kann zu brechen
welche deshalb sowie gemüse gesehen man
kann nicht gerade gar nicht gut so auf
jeden fall zwei esslöffel olivenöl
sommerrain und achtet beim olivenöl
biete jetzt machen die wenigsten auf
qualität nicht nochmal für 34 euro
preisgeld das ganze macht es richtig
cool so jetzt noch die zwei lehrer
esslöffel olivenöl und machen sie gerade
in diese gusseisen panik ihr könnt auch
eine edelstahl topf nehmen zb das ist
auch ein gutes heißen kopf aber das ist
eine produktplatzierung deswegen immer
bisher genau alles war so und jetzt
machen wir die ganzen kartoffeln und
karotten 3 warum ist man vielen fehlern
leben zuerst die zwiebeln aber mach das
bitte nicht frei
die kartoffeln und karotten brauchen
länger ja genau
und dann auf mittlerer stufe erst anfang
auf mittlerer stufe schön andünsten
richtig mag ja okay jetzt auch noch ein
löffel genau und dann auch mit
abstrichen an diensten
hier machen wir nachher wie gesagt
dieses dieses not rein und eindrücken
dran und hier in diesen topf machen wir
nachher den reich schön anbraten genau
soll das geht relativ schnell worauf
induktion so nummer 8 und zack fust
haben auch sofort und immer schön rühren
so und während wir dass währenddessen
wir alles bei mittlerer hitze gerade ein
bisschen vor uns hin köcheln lassen
ab und zu mal umrühren nur ab und zu
machen wir schon die anderen zutaten
denn genau die peperoni und diplomaten
richtig ok dann nimmst du die peperoni
nach tomaten sammrey kennst dich aus
balkan und ich nehme die wahl sind es
nun mal clever ronis genau
und die gibt es in jedem türkischen
supermarkt gibt es auf dem deutschen
supermarkt gibt es ja auch beim töten
weiß ich 100 das bekommt ihr habt nicht
jeder so und ich habe immer den verdacht
dass wenn sie ein bisschen heller sind
dass sie nicht so scharf sind und wenn
sie etwas dunkler sich
und oftmals wurde enttäuscht hat es
gestimmt war immer immer schaut manchmal
wissen sie aufgaben wirklich scharf sei
aber auf jeden fall nicht zu arg scharf
nehmen wir haben viele gewürze drin
fragt einfach nochmal bei onkel herunter
oder bei und lasagne oder kann ja auch
immer aus mir wird wahrscheinlich gut
afrikaner werden oder man kann ich ja
gute veganen durch durch wirklich schon
gegangen ja denken
durch die musik oder fleisch ja aber das
ist nicht so wie es ist oder fleisch
wirklich wir solchen und nehmen nicht
nur noch gekauft fertigen unsere kinder
auch in der türkische kuh sie muss die
für viele vegane
mit gemüse aber damals hat immer wenn
jemand im türkei urlaub geht und ich
schicke dann kriegt natürlich immer
dieses aderlasses höchst
unwahrscheinlich wie zum beispiel die
industrie mit welchen kosten das gemüse
extrem gemüse normalerweise die eltern
nicht so viel fleisch genau vielleicht
meist dann in den osten oder mittel
anatolia die ist die fleisch was man
auch sagen muss das fleisch in der
türkei teurer als in deutschland sehen
waren sind direkt deswegen mit dieser
wahnsinn für kapital für ein kilo
hackfleisch ist ungefähr 50 schlimmer
bis 150 kann man am rechner als 50
schüler also überlegt mal 1 wenn das so
sehen wenn es mit den löhnen vergleicht
ist um für ein kilogramm hackfleisch ist
für jürgen fehr kostet 50 euro in die
möglichkeit haben sich 80 90 euro
schneller es war wahnsinn überlegt mal
in augenschein code oder und pflegt sie
bei uns kilogramm ungefähr 35 euro und
in der türkei rund 80 euro
also wir müssen mit ihren löhnen
vergleich ist echter wahnsinn weil es
die linken haben es noch nicht geschafft
die fleisch sucht so richtig zu
industrialisieren massenvernichtung mit
tieren haben wir haben natürlich
hingekriegt
schade oder richtig erweisen bitte genau
ganz ganz wichtig und schlichter
wahnsinn jetzt haben dass klein
geschnitten wollte kein handy war dann
schnell ja mich wieso ein kleiner ninja
okay jetzt nehmen wir das alles und
gesagt du die panne genau und rühren
wieder die tomaten dazu will kann ja
genau das ist ja cool aus und fabian ist
richtig cool aus
komplett rainbow so wichtig ist dass er
das nicht zu früh sondern wirklich den
kartoffeln die zeit gibt richtig gar zu
werden aber auch nicht aber auch nicht
so dass er richtig weich sind wie sollen
schon schön bissfest sein sagt wenn du
kurz in wasser stimmen
das ist richtig weil das schmeckt nicht
dennoch ihr seht aber ich habe jetzt
auch gar kein wasser dazu gegeben weil
die tomaten von alleine besser
ok jetzt mal ein bisschen gehen wir von
mittlere stufe genau wissen hörgenau von
fünf auf sieben bei euch werden zb von
zwei auf drei ok man kann genau trockene
münze zuerst gleich ob in dem ins heim
zu bauen was ganz ganz einfaches und
dann machen wir ein esslöffel wollten
genau überhaupt noch mal halb ich mag
ihn zu machen
das könne nach dem geschmack machen wir
das möchtest dann als nächstes die
glocken läuten
ok und da war es war aber auch ein essay
willkommen das macht mir die hitze macht
ihr die nach eigenem maß da habe ich
auch ein teelöffel
so auch jetzt eine chance geben ok auch
im augenmaß und löffel salz okay was
fehlt ist doch volkan zumindestens für
die namen salat salat egal jetzt einfach
rum führen das riecht doch richtig
lecker muss ich ehrlich sagen
und obwohl ich in absoluter fleisch
fanatiker winzigen jetzt diensten
ich mag erholt aber manchmal ich benutze
auch die helle mehr englisch reden wir
nicht weil ich habe keine worte mehr
muss red onion sind
das war richtig cool kann richtig cool
so sagen dann lass uns noch mal
probieren hier aus auch ein
fleischfresser
er macht es auch
vegan ja wir gucken manchmal zusammen er
liegt hat er miracoli gemacht nude und
miracoli aus der fertig fanden aber
wahrscheinlich da das wettkochen ab und
zu eine mittagspause habe ich selber
jeder macht was eigenes oder man macht
zusammen erlebt geld zusammen oder wir
essen ist was da ist jetzt aber hier
alles wünschen die deckel draufmachen
schluss hatte ich darauf hinweisen
produktplatzierung ist und zwar das ist
der topf von der l und zwar der topf in
aller welt die er gern eintöpfe ist der
job von der sanierer das ist eine panne
die mag gern sohn ist so van gerichte
und der große dicke breite der top viel
essen rein passt oder auch toll schmeckt
immer ist der schwiegermutter die heiße
liebe und das ist wie gesagt und das ist
ein klein sagt vorbei auch wie viel
liter passen rein für ihre fast 50
bestellten waren sind schon groß aber
wie gesagt vier personen ideal
dann räumen wir inzwischen auf und
lassen es bisschen vor sich hin küche
und immer müssen aufpassen dass ich an
bringt braucht keine angst haben dass
olivenöl drin und natürlich auch die
tomaten bessern jetzt behinderung so was
manchen auch falsch verstehen wenn ihr
einen gusseisen trocknen dann ist es
wirklich so gut funktioniert nicht wenn
man das auf hoher hitze lange machen
kann kann man natürlich machen aber
gusseisen topf ist da um schoren
schonend zu garen das heißt nicht zu
einer hohen hitze der top bleibt lange
warten das heißt ich jetzt lange köcheln
lassen
auf mittlerer hitze nicht zu heiß um so
weniger temperatur hier nimmt umso mehr
nährstoffe bleiben darin enthalten
richtig richtig genau und richtig schön
köchelt wobei ich eigentlich auch
fairerweise sagen muss mit einem großen
topf kocht man nicht jeden tag oder und
ja ich mache ich im winter ich gerne
kommen im hinterkopf so ok alles da ich
mag halt diese schmorgerichte wenn
fleisch drin ist drin und müsen karotten
sind also augen zu drin
ja auf jeden fall die geschichte volkan
solange jetzt alles hier kocht tun wir
uns im salat vorbereitet in der
zwischenzeit so ein bisschen schneller
okay aber und ganz wichtig hier
august zeigen dem deckel kurz luft zur
seite legen ihr seht auch deswegen sind
diese nasen hier das ist gleichmäßig
bedröppelt wird und hier ist schon genug
wasser drin
die ganzen tomaten das ist ganz gemüse
kurz aufkochen lassen sagt bisschen
ausdünsten das schaffst du es zu flüssig
sondern auch den salat volkan tja was
ich das hier das ist eine wirklich
richtig und zwar brücke auf englisch
heißt gucken
das wusste ich dass ich kann eine
kühlkammer okay das heißt für mich ja so
kann man nicht wusste ich gar nicht
können okay dann machen wir kurz die die
die gurke schneiden
genau ganz wichtig wir wollen vorher
gesagt hat wie es heißt schicksals und
chaos sorgen heisst wirklich nicht mit
der gabel du musst den löffel essen
können und genau mit einem löffel alles
okay tomaten gurken küchen okay sonst
irgendwie riecht er wird jetzt sagen ist
doch egal was ich nachher alles zusammen
aber das ist nicht ein riesenunterschied
wie groß und man die sachen schneidet
das ist wirklich vom geschmack her kommt
das ganz anders ok dann schlagen wir die
brücke und alles und jetzt vor
schockiert dass ich nicht wusste was
wirklich auf englisch heißt wer es bitte
auch nicht wo es ist ich komme jetzt
richtig blöd vor wer wusste nicht dass
gurke auf englisch wie heißt drücken
will
mein gott werden sprachfehler ich kann
dieses ich würde sagen gleich google
ich habe es gleich und wie gesagt ganz
ganz klein schneiden das nur einen
löffel ist
[Musik]
und wie gesagt solange die guten
schleifen das ganze gemüse richtig klein
schneiden würfel schneiden
mache ich schon mal den reis und zwar
haben wir hier ein basmatireis wenn es
meine frau dabei würden türkischen reis
machen fast noch nicht mehr die typische
reißt aber neben basmatireis den krieg
jeder hin sogar beginnen und dann immer
hier gerade den nächsten top wir haben
schon drei liter wasser aufgesetzt und
ich muss ich ehrlich sagen ich glaube
ich immer mit dem reis gemacht aber
manchmal drei liter wasser
jetzt sind gerade diese basmatireis dann
tue ich einfach hier rein
die mengenangabe habe ich ja vorher
schon gesagt sowohl kann jetzt einfach
nur gucken kochen ja jetzt auch noch hin
so perfekt und hier kochen wir jetzt hin
was marti reisen und ich helfe volkan so
lange bank schieben
[Musik]
so der bekannte tauss auch den peperoni
nummer schneiden klein schneiden und wie
gesagt vor hat sich angesagt 1 bund
petersilie einen halben kopf drin halben
kunden machen wir jetzt hier rein und
bei der petersilie volkan die stimmen
auch okay alles klar
und jetzt ist auch weiter petersilie
auch ganz ganz wichtig weil es einfach
so ein krasser geschmack ist bitte so
klein wie möglich schneiden bei dem
messer ganz aufpassen auch ganz wichtig
messer niemals in die spülmaschine egal
was euch jemand erzählt messer niemals
in die spülmaschine kann verschiedene
faktoren haben ein ganz ganz wichtiger
ist dass die ganzen salze die er in den
spülmaschinen tabs habt nur die meisten
von euch rein machen leider dass das
material angreifen könnten und natürlich
auch wenn sie das ding verschiebt
dauernd an dem an dem korb an den
schwäbischen korb deswegen auch nicht
wie gesagt ich schnell ist gerade ging
war schon der wahnsinn oder dann richtig
stolz auf mich so richtig klein
schneiden und dann nehme ich einfach mal
zu machen das richtig die hand hier
drauf das ist stumpf da kann es schon
nicht verletzten normales messer zum
beispiel eine spitze hier kann schon
nicht verletzen einfach dran halten und
zack und bei dem messer auch immer ganz
ganz wichtig das macht das wirklich
jedes messer egal wie teuer messer ist
wenn irgendwann mal stimmt und kommt
darauf an immer wie oft jetzt benutzt
aber so alle sechs monate sollte das
will ich mal zum zum umfallen skizzen
waffenhändler der stadt die ganzen messe
auch schleifen und alle sechs monate
geben wir alle unsere messlatte nicht
teuer
wir zahlen jetzt dabei so sagen darf
sechs euro pro messer und dann haben ein
halbes jahr lang haben wir auf jeden
fall hohe und lange spaß an den messern
da weiß auch ganz genau was in winkel er
dann schleifen muss die schicht ist so
wahnsinn und einfach so durch jetzt
nämlich gerade das ding hier und co star
ein
richtig wollte hat ja und wir brauchen
die andere die andere halbe für die
essen was fressen die fiese aliens
machten vergessen ins es noch peter
sicherheit zumal wir haben nicht
vergessen wenn wir machen das erfüllen
das schmeckt ist ein bisschen bitter
aber wir machen das ganze zum schluss
rein gerne aber wir machen das rennen
nach dem crash war okay ganz wichtig
muss die saunas stimmrecht in die
petersilie die gladbecker situation
extrem geschmack das müssen wir nicht
ganz zum schluss rein macht und das
aroma nicht zu intensiv
also erst mit kichererbsen rein und ganz
zum schluss dann die petersilie kohl
wusste ich nicht coole idee so die
petersilie für unser gericht machen wir
auch gleich den stängel weg richtig war
kann steckt ja ja ich denke weg genau
und jetzt tue ich auch wieder klein
schneiden und 1 vorhersagen ganz wichtig
ab und so eine dicke luft
dass die feuchtigkeit hier raus geht das
nicht zu das ist uns zu in den super
wird also richtig schön reduzieren
endlich ist glauben und und ganz wichtig
der faktor ist wann es denn richtig
durch ist in den ab und zu mal könnte
man im kartoffel stück nehmen und
probieren und wenn es ganz hart anfasst
ich merkte es und wenn es die kartoffel
durch ist dann seid ihr so weit fertig
und so eine kartoffel nicht durch ist ab
und zu dann wieder einfach den deckel
drauf so dass hitze schon drin bleibt
sagt und jetzt mal nicht weiter
[Musik]
so was natürlich nicht normal
viele machen ich finde dass besonderes
orange einschneiden ja das machst du
gerne mal gar nicht weiß ist ich kenne
seinen salat anmachen die orange und was
wir auch machen wollen solange die
orange schneidet mache ich hier
die zitrone und zwar das war vor dem
rezept nicht mit drin aber eine zitrone
nach belieben noch nicht reinmachen
ich habe noch eine bio zitrone und jetzt
tut mir ganz ganz großen gefallen und
wales thema food wales diese zitrone
hier sollte es keine live ticker auf
ebendiese zitrone hier tue mir gefallen
tut es bei euch in die spülmaschine rein
und zwar da wo der tapferen ist es gibt
nur ein richtig cooles zitronenaroma
löst auch fleck durch die zitronensäure
ein richtig cooles ding dann stinkt
teure spülmaschine auch nicht und das
könnte ungefähr drei bis vier waschen
können das drin lassen ist kein problem
machen wir auch und zwar hier oben rein
ok schade management sagt und schneiden
aber ich können wir können wir kriegen
so einschneidend er könne mir ich würde
auch einsteigen ganz ehrlich ich finde
das macht doch mal so ein bisschen extra
coolen geschäft rein und was bei dem
salat an das sich außerhalb anderen
salat ist auch ganz wichtig zu sagen
normalerweise so ein blattsalat mit tut
mir denn ja erst am amt am tisch des
dressing braucht das ja nicht so lässig
wird hier soll aber alles schon richtig
cool reinziehen
deswegen mache jetzt mich folgendes das
kann ich jetzt machen sie dann schneidet
und zwar das olivenöl und hier ganz ganz
wichtig und kaltgepresstes olivenöl zu
nehmen ist es ganz ganz wichtig wie
gesagt es gibt raffinierte öle die
kannst zum braten neben olivenöle und es
gibt kaltgepresste und die wenn es kalt
gepresst wird ja auch nur für salate und
für normales brot oder sowas nehmen so
dann immer noch so mag und zwar beim
super g zwei teelöffel magst du machen
wir alles ist geschmackssache und zu
machen findet auch für jeden fall beim
türken und viele fragen immer wenn es
diese regel gibt es das gibt es in jedem
türkischen supermarkt oder beim 3 mori
entladen wie auch immer im ohr ich sehr
sehr bekannt essig gewürzt ein geniales
ding so da
machen wir noch ein bisschen chili
dreimal khadri genau weil die lieben
chili und da machen wir auch nach
geschmack dann machen wir noch ich will
sagen zwei teelöffel zwei teelöffel zack
und dann machen noch käfer schwarzem
pfeffer bitte immer auch ein teelöffel
viel lieber schwarzem pfeffer immer
frisch malen lasst euch nicht von apple
nimmt damit ich frisch gemahlenem
pfeffer
wir haben ja schon gemalt sagt dann noch
ein bisschen salz und zwar wenn man
einen halben teelöffel vulkanbedingten
einen halben teelöffel salz und dann was
bei keinem türkischen seite fehlen daran
typischen küchen auch nicht fehlen darf
ist granata versicherung und da ist auch
wichtig lasse mich veräppeln denn bitte
100% granata visierung kein öl ich mal
was gemisch das in der zukunft
und genau wer mich achtet das ist das
wort keinen ganzen coolen granatapfel
sierung kriegt man auch schon mal für 56
euro richtig und wichtig 70 wenn das
hier wäre froh wenn pinocchio hier
richtig bio damit sie bei 9 euro aber
macht des geistes der ist das übrigens
auch ewig haltbar und kanalisierung in
einer flasche auch angebrochen
sämtlicher zwei jahren genau das haben
und dass man richtig drüber
und das ist wirklich so ein geheimnis
der türkischen küche oder des salates
granatapfel sirup das ist richtig cool
perfekt
jetzt machen wir noch keine orangen so
fesselnd vulkan vor lauter vor lauter
schönheit haben wir verpennt den den
dingen zu schalten wie cool ist dass man
so ein backofen hat der dann sich
automatisch abstellt
so hat meine ich erkenne ich war jetzt
weiß ich warum meinst du meinst du nicht
das gefühl neue zwiebeln mit mein gott
fangen wir an veganen küche zu weinen
wegen in zwiebeln so ein bisschen runter
geschaltet wurde kann auf 6 richtig so
wenn ich jetzt jamie oliver wäre dann
würde ich folgendes jetzt machen die
lippen meinen bus bringen da reingehen
und es darf ich mal umsetzen da drin da
ich habe richtig oliver will und auch
kein engländer werden
lippel machen richtig schön mal
verrühren immer die farben auf menschen
kohl das aussieht und was ganz ehrlich
sagen ich glaube der salat ist
mindestens für sechs oder für sechs
leute ok also bei den mengenangaben
bitte nicht zu arg darauf achten lieber
ein bisschen weniger beim salat weil das
ist wird für sechs sieben leute gemacht
soll jetzt zieht der mal und jetzt tut
mir wieder eingefallen ich weiß es ist
jeder ihrem stress die kinder nerven
der laden macht bald zu das passiert das
passiert erst ein anruf bitte lasst den
verlagen einfach mal kurz unheimlich
schnell zieht oder richtig schön
durchziehen lassen dann richtig geladen
und dann merkte man eine richtige
geschmacks explosion mit der geld mit
dem essig baum gehört mit den orangen
darin richtig genial
und wie gesagt nicht an volkan vorbei
gesagt hat schon kleinen löffel wollen
genau wie ist der balkan vorhergesagt
hat was ist ein schicksal das schicksal
des ortes er heißt einfach hier ein
löffel voll
ohne spaß machen und zwar sei es ein
bisschen salz warum weil weil er in der
schärfe drin ist die schärfe ein
bisschen raus
auch noch ein bisschen olivenöl rein
machen genau das ein bisschen ruckeln
heißt bei uns olivenöl und zwar habe ich
hier olivenöl so perfekt olivenöl kannst
du nie zu wenig machen
übrigens wenn es nicht wusste der der
grieche verbraucht im jahr weist es
jemand weiß über 22 liter olivenöl
person ab wahnsinn und der deutschen
oder die wissen dass eine solche braucht
zwei liter
warum man kann sie sagen bei
sonnenblumenöl 69 cent kostet und
olivenöl sieben euro genau das ist das
wunder ist sie musste sie billige
olivenöl musste ich den designer
das rad ist jetzt fertig war konnten sie
lasse noch ein bisschen kuscheln wir ein
bisschen auf ihr okay oder mehr
probieren kurzen aber wir haben schon
munter okay ich möchte nicht dass
irgendwann sagt braun
da ist im mund und was weiß nicht was
nahen ende mich noch jamie oliver ja
ohne witz der westen eingreifen oder
alles reinstopfen wahrscheinlich das war
natürlich nicht wir sind kein immer
waren
deswegen haben fehler gemacht
das liegt immer an der kathode
kontrollieren ob es durch ist
das kommt wieder die kartoffel ist fast
durch also fast durch das ist genau der
richtige moment
und zwar für die herbst wird der frisch
kaufen oder in der dose im dose ist
schon im wasser eingelegt es ist kein
unterschied es gibt kein besser oder
schlechter
hier spart euch einfach keine zeit denn
normalerweise erbsen einen tag vorher
tut es besser so wenn euch jetzt mal
passiert dass bei der dose angriff
abgebrochen ist da gibt es eine ganz
ganz gut weiß auch für den karlsruher
kann wenn immer einfach die andere dose
server kann und machst du das
aufgabenfeld schaffst du perfekt
funktioniert jetzt sind wir die dose und
zwar immer mit eingefallen jetzt mal
fielen den fehler und werfen das wasser
hier drin weg das ist so genial dieses
wasser vom kichererbsen aus kichererbsen
wasser ist ein genialer als ersatz für
das ist absolute einsatz weil es so die
konsistenz von dem iphone im wasser hier
drin ist richtig denkt so richtig weiß
mäßig und nicht wegschmeißen das können
nachher brauchen und wir werden es
nachher nochmal kurz brauche nicht sagen
warum so jetzt haben ist fairtrade rosen
aus kenia oder jetzt nimmer das einfach
du musst einfach reinschieben
wenn ihr jetzt merken sollte wenn ihr
jetzt merken sollte
das ist das zu viel flüssigkeit weg ist
sind ja einfach den salat löwen pass
auch kein problem wenn ihr jetzt merken
sollte das ein bisschen flüssigkeit
fehlt mir einfach ein bisschen
kichererbsen machen und zwar zum teil
von dem killer apps masse und schütte
nummer 1
jetzt noch ein bisschen feuchtigkeit
noch reingekriegt sondern lass mal ein
bisschen noch aufkochen und jetzt kommt
das nächste was den wolken gesagt hat
als kleinen tipp weil der geschmack
einfach so so extrem ist jetzt noch am
schluss richtung burg hat was machen
nicht alles ein bisschen okay
das richtig gut wahnsinn das ist echt
cool freue mich richtig drauf megane
setzen wollte und vor allem gesund und
frisch das extrem viel prozent und
kichererbsen wird immer wichtiger weil
die erbsen braucht ein wenig wasser ganz
ganz wichtig wächst überall in der
türkei im nahen osten indien wächst
kichert wechselt kichererbsen wie
unkraut ist echt wahnsinn der ganz ganz
coole frucht extrem resistent und
proteinreiche extrembereich von
rohstoffen wo man dran ist alles dran
vitamin b c d e f bis z ist alles drin
hier in den topf also eine ganz ganz
coole geschichte
jetzt haben auch die vorteile eines
cousens top gusseisen kopfes und zwar
haben die kinder rein gemacht hätte
hätten sie ja schon durch
jetzt folgen ist wir machen den topf
ziemlich aus wenn der topf wie scheiß
der speichert die wärme schon
gespeichert der ist richtig war und erst
einmal nämlich folgendes den deckel zu
energie sparen einfach jetzt an lassen
und jetzt ungefähr 20 minuten 15 bis 20
minuten köcheln lassen fertig bürger
nicht wissen ehrlich zu euch und beten
dass jetzt auch faken können aber was
mir völlig fremd haben war der reis und
zwar haben den reiz haben wir zu viel
wasser genommen viel zu viel wasser man
nimmt normalerweise immer ein einteiler
rey und weihwasser
wir haben drei liter wasser rein gemacht
in vergessen wir völlig mist gebaut und
der reis ist so richtig lag jetzt reiß
ist nicht so könig natürlich schmeißen
reisen es nicht weg oder machen sondern
einfach mehr essen das ist einfach das
essen ist so genial da ist der reis nun
die beilagen fertig oder und der ja der
schmeckt halt der stadt voll weit käme
das einem reichen sowieso milchpreis ist
und was sie nachts nicht machen ja
nachtisch mache ich damit wir konnten
keinen reis kochen mein gott was gibt
doch schon was gibt es noch einfacher
ist als reich zu kommen wir haben jetzt
eine band mein gott zu mir leid
vielleicht merkt das ja mal gar nicht
jetzt werden nämlich den tisch
verrichten
und wie gesagt ich habe noch ein
bisschen petersilie die machen ist ganz
zum schluss noch rein wenn ich bin ich
serviere und jetzt kommen die jungs und
lass das mal probieren oder ja ok genau
so sehr mag und mutter tish und anlassen
probieren so jetzt ist meinem tisch hier
haben wir die fraktion veganer rechts
von mir und links die zeugen jehovas
tschuldigung tyrannosaurus rex
fleischesser
das heißt wir können jetzt mal gucken
was an dem spiel ich ehrlich sein ganz
ähnlich schmeckt dann sagte ich sage ich
steige rein den reis hama versammelt das
volk hat das total versammelt kreis ist
es geht also die kameras falsch machen
wie kann man nur viermal der reise ist
nicht so toll aber trotzdem ich möchte
nichts davon nehmen sagt mir ganz ganz
ehrlich es ist absolut vegan
es ist auch kein fake oder sowas
probleme was wir gemacht haben
kichererbsen das nennt sich notwehr ganz
voll mit mit gemüse da vorne haben wir
einen salat und zwar nennt sich dieser
salat löffel salat und zwar einmal alles
von einem löffel essen kann
okay das noch mal probieren ihr müsst
verstehen warum so wenig schlecht nein
das stimmt doch gar nicht jetzt kann ich
sagen ja ich weiss nicht schlecht machen
spaß
der ist echt klasse ihr seid vielleicht
nach euren job los was anderes aber
wurst genau wegen geld schaffte keiner
habe ich recht genau
[Musik]
das ist irgendwie den weg sagen das
problem ist wenn du etwas sagt tusche
die anderen beeinflussen ok allee bis
jetzt alles was er sagen wollte
merkt ihr was ganz besonders beim salat
hätte man salatbars auf kommen wir jetzt
was sagen ja das sagen
ja das ist mir aufgefallen okay ich
liebe ja und was ist noch drin und salat
jastrow nie was noch da schon etwas ganz
besonderes drin was ein normaler weise
im salat reingehört richtig gut gemacht
den reis nicht besser als ich david weiß
kombiniert mit
nun machen sie machen das sorry trete
man ganz kurz über die kichererbsen wie
findet er ist ein cooler fleischersatz
oder ja immer du bist eben dazu er ist
ein cooler fleischersatz ja ich muss
aber als nehmen genau genau das kann man
als herzens lassen
genau diese kinder bestimmt sie habe
natur als fleischfresser der rallye
jetzt auch essen
ein anderer teil wird es dafür bezahlen
[Gelächter]
würde oder würde sagen es ist eine
vollwertige mahlzeit
also wir haben es hingekriegt wir haben
die veganer überzeugt wir haben die
zeugen jehovas überzeugt die d s fleisch
esser überzeugt ich fand es auch cool
macht es viel zu hause nach ihr seht es
ganz ganz einfach das ist ein längeres
video aber wenn es zu hause alleine
macht seite fertig in 20 minuten weiss
mal maximal 20 zubereitungszeit mich
kochzeit dass er eine stunde dran
eine richtig coole geschichte und wenn
jemand veganer zu besuch gehabt habe
zwei möglichkeiten in ihr ladet sie aus
oder ihr macht zu uns so richtig cool
ok coole geschichte sorgt ist stolz auf
mich sehr wohl
[Musik]
kameras aus wie schmeckt nämlich alex
auch der reiskammer gerne in der salza
nur wenn salz hersteller geht es ok war
die kombination ihrer wir haben gedacht
das im reis macht ich weiß ich hab ja
schon erstmal mein leben mein video ist
eine ähnliche natürlich du weißt dass
ich koche ich glaub ich hab hier kommt
ja aber ich weiß aber warum etwas haben
werden
die haben was am vulkan es gibt nur zwei
zutaten beim reis wasser und reis aber
wir haben wasser vergessen hat ok
[Musik]